de dali aux mythologies et avec notre
bonjour à vos clients vous êtes
consultant de france 24 sur les
questions stratégiques on imagine déjà
que cette conférence de presse commune
était nécessaire que les états unis
elles manifestaient leur soutien à la
pologne alors kamala harris qui promet
donc une assistance militaire à la
pologne pas à l'ukraine on va y revenir
mais d'abord ça veut dire quoi renforcer
le système de défense de la pologne
très concrètement ça veut dire
poursuivre tous qui depuis 2014 est dans
les tuyaux et qui donc depuis
l'invasion et l'annexion d'une partie
territoire en 2014 et puis ça veut dire
avant même 2014 pour suivre un certain
nombre de coopération qui relevait
davantage du bilatéral de la relation
américano polonaise bien sûr dans un
cadre au temps mais ça signifie des
armes stratégiques
alors elle l'a invoqué parce que
évidemment la question l'article 5 c'est
la question de la défense territoriale
c'est la question de la
france des mousquetaires qu'évidemment
c'est ça qui fait qu'aujourd'hui tous
les pays de la première ligne de défense
du flan s comme l'a redit ce sont
évidemment les plus inquiets comme
depuis 2014 sont les pays qui évidemment
ont été les plus allants les plus
demandeurs d'une présence alliés et a
fortiori américaine souvenez-vous
peut-être de fortes trump 1 lorsque
l'administration polonaise tendait la
main à l'amérique demandait l'équivalent
d'une base américaine permanente ce qui
pouvait être interprété à l'époque comme
potentiellement une mesure un peu escale
à thouars au sens où on aurait
finalement à donner le change à la
russie devenant une sorte de loi du
talion au lieu d'essayer de penser plus
intelligemment et aussi à l'époque on se
disait que c'était peut-être dangereux
de quelque sorte fossilisés toutes nos
forums un ensemble de force majeure sur
le flanc est alors même que les menaces
étaient multidimensionnelle
vigueur est ce qu'il faut comprendre
aussi guillaume sait que la pologne qui
pour l'instant joue un rôle important en
terme d'aidé humanitaire à l'accueil un
million cinq cent mille de réfugiés
cranham est ce que ça voudrait dire
aussi que la pologne est une potentielle
cibler ce qu'elles pourraient être
attaquées par les russes est le message
qui est envoyé aujourd'hui c'est
attention message de réassurance c'est
clair c'est un message de réassurance
les scénarios qui qui qui nous ferait
discuter plus concrètement de du
scénario enfin de l'hypothèse très très
sombres en fait que vous envisagez qui
en fait est une hypothèse de guerre
entre l'alliance atlantique et la russie
on en est loin et suez mais ça renvoie
géré aux grands points de suite et je
ne pas monopoliser la parole mais ça
renvoie aux grands points de fuite en
fait de cette double intervention qui
intervient au lendemain de la clôture du
tout le débat sur
l'envoi de mig-29 polonais ah ah ah là
là là ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la
résistance ukrainienne en échange de f16
donc puisque la pologne john mais moi
aussi j'aurais besoin évidemment un mode
de en fait comblé les trous et
d'ailleurs on voit que derrière c'est
finalement les f-35 accélérer la
livraison des chars des dd est français
qui sont ces avions de cinquième
génération américains etc donc on voit
bien que il ya cet aspect là qui le
point de chute de 2 des échanges entre
le président polonais et la
vice-présidente américaine qu on ne
parle pas de l'assistance militaire
évidemment voir kamala harris est allé
en quelque sorte en opérations de
sauvetage au colmatage dans l'alliance
pollono américaine et au delà l'alliance
atlantique reste forte mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une logique
en fait de deux de réduction du champ
des possibles en matière d' aide
militaire à l'ukraine et qu'on va
diriger vers ce que certains analystes
avaient envisagé depuis un moment c'est
à dire des armes légères quelque chose
qui de toute façon renvoi c'est à dire
évidemment tout ce qui va concerner de
l'infanterie de ce qui va permettre en
fait d'attaqués sur l'arrière toutes les
lignes logistiques russie les missiles
ont touché évidemment
les missiles antichars font partie de
dordogne que les missiles sol air
peuvent faire partie de cette panoplie
même à un niveau je dirais encore plus
léger si vous passez souvent dans ce
domaine comme militaire c'est évidemment
des mines antipersonnel des lunettes de
vision nocturne un certain nombre
d'éléments qui vont permettre à la fois
en guérilla urbaine est à la fois pour
venir encore une fois augmenter les
coûts de delà des avancées russe et de
la stratégie sur le terrain donc on va
se diriger une meilleure note sur ce
plan militaire un qui n'enlève en rien
la pertinence de toutes les zones linda
toutes les autres lignes d'action
politique diplomatique et y compris de
la société civile puisque le président
dawda rendu hommage aux populations
polonaises moi c'est tout un effort de
détermination et d'ailleurs qui
rejaillit sur l'équation militaire plus
on est déterminés france montrent unis
plus on est crédible sur le plan
militaire mais fondamentalement à ce
stade la crédiblité surplomb militaires
de notre aide elle est très limité et je
crois que en creux l'absence de toute
mention de ces de cette aide militaire
dans le cas à ce stade un du dialogue
entre kamala harris et le président
polonais témoigne de cette cette réalité
et le président ukrainien qui n'a eu de
cesse un certain moment de dire que les
occidentaux elle avait en quelque sorte
lâcher ou en tout cas qu'il était bien
seul il ya eu cette question de zone
d'exclusion aérienne qui n'a pas été
contenter leurs tiroirs on imagine qu'on
n'y arrivera pas et là encore c'est très
difficile à la fois de de galvaniser le
peuple ukrainien est d'obtenir le
maximum de ses marques du point de vue
de venise à minsk c'est très difficile à
la fois de maintenir le moral de
maintenir le lien avec son peuple et en
même temps de 10 de tout le monde at il
fait beaucoup plus lentement c'est le
fondement même temps est ce qu est ce
que c pas refaire le fondement c'est
évidemment la résistance et la vigueur
de du peuple ukrainien c'est à dire que
c'est une guerre existentielle pour eux
bien davantage en ce sens que pour les
russes sûr que le peuple russe est
néanmoins c'est c'est quand même une
logique de passage à une forme de guerre
en irak ou conventionnelle de guerre qui
va qui va se faire avec des moyens de
plus en plus limitées et encore une fois
c'est le principe de la symétrie c'est
le principe du faible au fort c'est
peut-être aussi une des leçons qu'on
peut on ne peut s'empêcher quand on a
étudié les différents conflits de
l'après guerre froide de penser aux
balkans de penser avec la lampe lauzon
négoce la vie dans les années 90 c'est
de voir que à l'époque aussi set face à
la serbie qui n'était pas une grande
puissance militaire mais qui dominait
très largement les autres anciennes à un
ferment de la fération de cela mais on a
eu le développement de stratégies
asymétrique et on sent bien que sur le
plan quand il faut strictement militaire
c'est vers ce site qu'on se dirige vers
le verra dans les prochains jours alors
merci beaucoup guillaume de peinture